[Music]
you went to comic-con yeah I love going
I go every year how was it
it was awesome so you know people like
dress up as the favorite superheroes and
stuff I saw the best thing I've ever
seen at a Comic Con this time I saw a
guy I don't know how else to describe it
I saw like a really overweight guy in a
Superman outfit waiting for the elevator
[Laughter]
powers clearly the reality was his
kryptonite I was there I visited Comic
Con once and it is it is intense like so
many people you walk around it's it's
it's a lot going on it's harder for me
because I like I don't pee all day whoo
and I'm there mm-hmm
just cuz the bathrooms are so filled Oh
guys bathrooms are already like the
filthiest like urinals are just women
don't know this are like surrounded by a
lake of urine and we're somehow like we
don't talk about it right every guy's
shoes are coated in the piss of a
thousand strangers
I walk around a lot of guys that aren't
that careful about you know where
they're aiming it's just you know
everywhere just go everywhere as long as
you're in the bathroom you could do
whatever you want yeah so so I try to
avoid but I was at the Barnes & Noble
and I really had to go inside go in and
there's four urinals so I have to do the
quick math of like which one has the
least urine under it yeah but just when
there's a lake under each one and
they're rivers running horrible yeah so
I picked the one closer to the wall for
just away from all the badness luckily
it's empty nobody's there I go to the
one closer to the wall about to start
peeing and this guy comes in there's
four urinals and he comes in he stands
right next to me right I'm like that's
kind of weird and you can't really
you're not looking over at oh I'm not
looking at it and then I hear him say to
himself but just loud enough that I
heard he said uh eyes forward Gary
there's nobody else there
so he has to talk himself into the game
of not staring so I'm like alright
that's weird I'm gonna wait for this guy
to go thirty seconds go by and I hear
him go eyes forward Gary no so he's
losing the battle yeah absolutely so I
work up my courage and I look out of the
corner of my eye I can see what's going
on and there's a guy and on his
shoulders is a little two-year-old boy
staring right at my dear
[Laughter]
[Applause]
forward Gary scary yeah sure Gary we
make direct eye contact with each other
and then he goes right back down to the
show yeah yeah yeah of course who names
their kid Gary also that's not the
question I'd be asking